wir sind unterwegs im osten der ukraine
anna timofte war von der
hilfsorganisation polisca nimmt uns mit
in die dörfer an der frontlinie wo sich
sonst kaum jemand hin traut das dorf
majors liegt direkt an der frontlinie
von den einst 1000 einwohnern die hier
einmal gelebt haben sind die meisten
längst geflohen die 200 die
zurückgeblieben sind haben nun angst
dass sich ihre situation weiter
verschlimmern könnte heute bringt anna
der 74-jährigen riesa medikamente die
rentnerin lebt hier ganz allein seit dem
ihr mann ende letzten jahres an corona
gestorben ist
da hinten sind die soldaten kämpfer die
stellungen gehen rund um das dorf haben
sie angst möchte ich wissen wie soll ich
sagen natürlich haben wir angst wenn es
kracht dann schreist du lisa möchte mir
ihr haus zeigen überall spuren von
einschlägen die sieben jahre dauerte
militärische konflikt schon und nun
droht alles wieder schlimmer zu werden
die leute versuchen weniger nach draußen
zu gehen
die situation ist leider nicht gut die
angst ist zurück gekehrt 2014 zu beginn
des krieges wurde das dorf schon einmal
zerstört mit deutschen hilfsgeldern
daran erinnern die plaketten überall in
den häusern wurden viele dächer neu
gebaut gibt es nun einen neuen krieg
welches live scoring ist presseoffizier
der ukrainischen armee
er will der welt seine sicht der dinge
zeigen im dorf führt er uns zu den
letzten einschlägen vor drei tagen erst
sagt er soll hier eine mine explodiert
seien
zum glück waren die bewohner nicht da
wir erleben hier jeden tag angriffe
was sage ich hab das ja selbst gehört
das sind auch die daran erinnere ich
nochmal nach dem münchner abkommen
verboten sind
welches lauf nimmt mich mit in seinem
auto wir fahren durch die region donetsk
unterwegs mit der ukrainischen armee
das ist hier die einzige möglichkeit
sich durch das umkämpfte gebiet zu
bewegen überall warnen schilder vom
ihnen auch wir hören immer wieder
explosionsgeräusche aus weiter
entfernung in den schützengräben durch
die uns die ukrainischen soldaten führen
wird klar mit welch einfachen mitteln
sie hier kämpfen mit einem alten
fernrohr darf ich rüber schauen
von hier aus kann ich die andere seite
sehen die stellungen der separatisten
die von russland unterstützt werden auch
gefährlich die stelle wird immer wieder
auch beschossen
auf die andere seite können wir nicht
dafür bräuchten wir eine spezielle
erlaubnis die separatisten
auch können wir die checkpoints in das
von separatisten kontrollierte gebiet
nicht einfach passieren wir haben nur
eine akkreditierung um mit der
ukrainischen armee zu drehen
viele soldaten die wir treffen sind
wehrpflichtige und männer die ihre
bürgerliche existenz aufgegeben haben um
an die front zu gehen einige sind
juristen einer ist kunsthistoriker
alexander ist banker erzählt er uns wir
haben schwere zeiten und unser land
braucht mehr soldaten als banker wir
stehen hier an der grenze und
verteidigen unser territorium und die
unabhängigkeit unseres landes liegen die
soldaten wissen alleine kann die
ukrainische armee den krieg gegen
russland nicht gewinnen nicht einmal
führen
die hoffnung liegt auf europa und
amerika gemeinsam mit internationaler
unterstützung können wir einfluss oder
druck auf russland machen damit sie die
eskalation nicht weiter tragen können
sie sich denn vorstellen
das ist eine eskalation leider kann ich
mir das vorstellen aber wir sind absolut
vorbereitet welches live zeigt mir ein
video das er gerade aufgenommen hat der
krieg zwischen russland und der ukraine
ist von anfang an auch ein
informationskrieg deshalb posten die
soldaten der zehnten regale ihre version
des konfliktes auf ihrer eigenen
facebook-seite aufnahmen der minen wie
sie schreiben russisches militär mit
drohnen vor allem in
letzten wochen immer häufiger in den
dörfern abwirft wenn die soldaten sie
finden sprengen sie sie gezielt mit
einem schuss der ukrainische standpunkt
ist klar der aggressor sitzt in moskau
das ist ein internationaler konflikt
unter der führung von russland alle
operationen werden in russland geplant
die führung sitzt in russland die
kommandos die im fernsehen nicht zu
sehen sind und der einsatz der kämpfer
erfolgt durch russische offiziere anna
führt jeden tag einen ganz anderen kampf
auch ihr ist wichtig dass deutschland
davon erfährt denn nur mit
internationaler finanzieller
unterstützung kann die hilfsorganisation
polisca die menschen versorgen vom
ukrainischen staates können sie wenig
erwarten
tamara lebt seit 62 jahren im dorf
mallorca seitdem es kein gas mehr gibt
muss sie mühsam jeden tag ihren kleinen
rufen selbst in gang bringen
wir hören im fernsehen russlands die
truppen zusammen
die ukraine zieht truppen zusammen ich
wünsche mir dass sie eine gemeinsame
sprache finden
wir sind als slawischen völker
miteinander doch durch familien
verbunden
die familie der rentnerin lebt auf
beiden seiten der konfliktlinie auch
deshalb wünscht sie sich endlich frieden
auch das ist einer von vielen eindrücken
die wir mitnehmen von der frontlinie
eines konfliktes der jetzt wieder im
blick der weltöffentlichkeit steht
[Musik]